[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend man wird doch träumen dürfen
eine parlamentarische demokratie wie die
deutsche darf ein ideal in sich tragen
an dem reale regierungschefinnen oder
chefs dann gemessen werden die sollen
seien von der mehrheit des volkes
getragen ausgestattet mit weisheit
besonnenheit und tatkraft gesegnet mit
der gabel staat und volk für gemeinsame
ziele zu begeistern ein geschickter
feuriger rede dass deutschlands neu
gewählter kanzler nicht alle diese
qualitäten gleichermaßen vollendet zur
verfügung hat wurde heute deutlich vor
dem bundestag in seiner
regierungserklärung
premiere so etwas wie temperament zeigte
der hanseat aus dem norden nur zu einem
punkt dass viele schon auf lars
berichtet er kommt eher unauffällig
daher der mann mit der aktentasche wird
gleich seine erste regierungserklärung
abgeben die ist mit fast 90 minuten
rekordverdächtig lang und zu beginn
ungewohnt deutlich olaf scholz
attackiert radikale corona leugner die
den zusammenhalt im land gefährden
würden
der hasserfüllten die mit packe menschen
mit gewalt und morddrohungen uns alle an
greift werden wir mit allen mitteln
unseres demokratischen rechtsstaats
entgegentreten unsere demokratie ist
eine wehrhafte demokratie was die
restlichen 80 minuten folgt ist der
bekannte scholz der ihn fast schon
merkels manier ohne größere emotionen
ausführlich den koalitionsvertrag der
ampel vorträgt mindestlohn erhöhung
bürgergeld kohleausstieg für uns liegen
große aufgaben und entscheidende
weichenstellung
weichenstellungen die wir jetzt
vornehmen weil wir jetzt den richtigen
zirkus in die zukunft einschlagen müssen
wir haben keine zeit zu verlieren aber
es ist an diesem tag nicht nur stolz der
seine rolle noch sucht ähnlich geht es
der union die nach 16 jahren auf der
oppositionsbank platz und fraktionschef
brinkhaus der um seinen posten fürchten
muss bietet auf der einen seite der
regierung zusammenarbeit an scheut aber
auch nicht die attacke ich erwarte von
einem bundeskanzler in der ersten
regierungserklärung nicht das eher
kleinteilig den koalitionsvertrag der
verliert sondern
ich erwarte dass er die großen linien
zeit sollte die opposition gehofft haben
vielleicht den einen oder anderen spalt
in der ampel zu entdecken so wird sie
enttäuscht zu besichtigen ist er ein
dick aufgetragener schulterschluss der
neuen fraktionsvorsitzenden von fdp und
grünen aber
so energisch haben sie nicht regiert in
den letzten jahren ihre
regierungspolitik
die konservativen haben hier seit vielen
jahren eine moderne und eine
unideologische einwanderungspolitik
verhindert diesen historischen fehler
werden wir korrigieren gewohntes gibt es
heute vor allem von der afd die wählt
für ihre kritik wieder einmal den
verbalen vorschlaghammer
der lärmende fehlstart in ihre aus
linksgrünen betonköpfen und umgefallene
liberalen zusammen gezimmerte regierung
hingelegt hat sucht seinesgleichen
bundeskanzler scholz will deutschland
digitalisieren
klimaneutral und sozialer machen der
elan der dafür nötig ist flammte
allerdings rhetorisch in seiner
regierungserklärung eher selten auf
und im schatten der regierungserklärung
und der debatte darüber tat sich heute
ein neues konfliktfeld auf alle anderen
gegen die afd es geht um die vorsitze in
ausschüssen des bundestages
innenausschuss gesundheitsausschuss
entwicklungsausschuss hätten nach alten
gepflogenheiten an afg abgeordnete gehen
sollen und keiner von denen kam heute
durch david gebhard berichtet dreimal an
diesem tag eröffnet
bundestags-vizepräsident kubicki
ausschuss sitzungen bei denen die afg
hofft ihren jeweiligen kandidaten für
den vorsitz durchzubekommen insbesondere
hier im mächtigen innenausschuss doch
dreimal fallen afd bewerber durch mit
der verjährung alle drei
ausschussvorsitze
haben wir hier einen bruch mit allen
parlamentarischen gepflogenheiten zu
verzeichnen den mann als historisch
bezeichnen muss ich würde davon ausgehen
dass alle mitglieder des
innenausschusses ihre gründe hatten so
abzustimmen und so ist das in der
demokratie wenn man in wahlen keine
mehrheiten bekommt wird man nicht
gewählt ich kann ja jetzt auch überhaupt
nichts demokratie problematisches drin
sehen der in den ausschuss kontrolliert
unter anderem auch behörden wie dem
inlandsgeheimdienst gleichzeitig werden
teile der fdp vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet wohl ein grund für die
ablehnung ein anderer der konkrete
kandidat hess hier war zu erwarten oder
ist zu erwarten aufgrund aus seiner
bisherigen tätigkeit dass er eher
spalterisch und hetzerisch in den
letzten monaten und jahren agiert hat
insofern nicht geeignet ist und diesen
ausschuss vorsitz zu übernehmen
zuvor waren auch die af die bewerber um
den vorsitz im ausschuss für
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und dem im
pandemie zeiten wichtigen
gesundheitsausschuss durchgefallen
katrin göring eckardt ist für die grüne
partei im präsidium des deutschen
bundestages und damit mitverantwortlich
für die parlamentarischen regeln und
gepflogenheiten
guten abend nach berlin ich grüße sie
herr kleber ist gelten diese alten
regeln für die afg jetzt nicht mehr
durch die alten regeln gelten genau das
was immer gegolten hat dass parteien
vorschlags rechte haben und dass das
nach einem zugriff systemen geht es ein
bisschen kompliziert aber letzten endes
geht es darum dass alle parteien im
deutschen bundestag vertreten sind auch
zugriffsrechte auf ausschussvorsitzende
haben aber nicht im sinne von sieben
nennen dann einfach jemanden sondern im
sinne von sie haben ein vorschlagsrecht
ist anders bei den mitgliedern die
werden benannt die sind dann auch im
ausschuss bei den vorsitzenden ist es so
das ist ein vorschlagsrecht es und
dieses mal haben wir in allen
ausschüssen gewählt nun ist es so dass
man so 70 jahre parlamentsgeschichte und
gepflogenheiten außerhalb der
geschriebenen regeln nicht so ganz
kaltschnäuzig über bord schmeißen kann
trotzdem ist das heute als neuerung
passiert denn drei nicht unwichtigen
ausschüsse
erhalten heute sie war das nicht sondern
es war natürlich überlegt dass man in
einer geheimen wahl in einer
demokratischen geheimen wahl sagt ja es
gibt dieses vorschlagsrecht und dann
entscheiden die parlamentarierinnen und
parlamentarier ob sie die person die da
vorgeschlagen ist auch wählen wollen wir
haben das ja ähnlich bei den vize
präsidenten
ich kann mich nicht erinnern weil es vor
meiner zeit im bundestag und auch vor
der deutschen wiedervereinigung war
sowas gab es zum beispiel auch bei
grünen vize präsidenten dass sie nicht
gewählt worden sind vom parlament also
es ist nichts ganz neues aber es ist
eben auch eine klare ansage der
demokraten und der bisher galt zwischen
den etablierten parteien nennen wir sie
mal so eine art übereinkunft dass man
der afd nicht eine märtyrer rolle gönnt
und deshalb ihnen die parlamentarischen
rechte nicht vorenthalten wird selbst
wenn man mehrheiten dafür hätte bisher
galt das so werden jetzt neue saiten
aufgezogen
der parlamentarische rechte hat die auch
die selbstverständlich sie haben
redezeiten im deutschen bundestag sie
müssen sich an regeln halten auch an die
korona regeln im haus natürlich aber sie
haben alle parlamentarischen rechte und
gleichwohl kann natürlich einen
ausschuss sagen wir möchten von dieser
person die uns da vorgeschlagen wird
nicht im vorsitz vertreten werden und
genau das ist passiert das ist
demokratie und ich finde es übrigens
auch eine gute gepflogenheit dass man
nicht einfach ein automatismus hat
sondern dass man sich tatsächlich immer
noch mal entscheidet ob man eine person
wählen will beispielsweise im
innenausschuss oder im
gesundheitsausschuss wo es ja wirklich
auch um was geht und wo die frage ist
wer repräsentiert endlich sind ausschuss
auch nach außen dass ein parlamentarier
parlamentarierinnen sagen nein von
dieser person möchten wir nicht
vertreten werden so ähnlich lief dass er
tatsächlich sie haben sie im vergleich
selber schon herangezogen wie mit dem
vize präsidenten posten für die afg die
haben andauernd neue kandidaten
vorgeschlagen und jedes mal gab es eine
abstimmung und dann sagt man ja hoch den
nun aber nur leider nicht schlagbar neun
vor und am ende der es der amtsperiode
des letzten bundestages gab es halt
immer noch kein fdp vize präsidenten
wird das jetzt wiederholt in den
arbeitskreisen in den ausschüssen in
denen wirklich der kern der
parlamentarischen arbeit getan hat ja
der kern der parlamentarischen arbeit
wird auch getan auch hoffentlich von den
fdp abgeordneten die ja nicht häufig
auch nicht da sind und ganz andere
agenda haben und sich nicht wirklich an
der debatte im ausschuss beteiligen ist
mir jedenfalls häufig berichtet worden
aber ganz klar ist natürlich findet dort
die sachliche die inhaltliche arbeit
statt mit allen fraktionen und es geht
um die frage wer einen ausschussvorsitz
und wer ihnen dann auch nach außen
vertritt nun gehören sie ja und
passenderweise zum sogenannten
ältestenrat des deutschen bundestages
der jetzt die sache übernehmen und
beraten ist da überhaupt eine lösung
noch drin drei ausschüsse haben im
moment keinen vorsitzen die werden dann
wahrscheinlich einen vize vorsitzenden
einen vize vorsitzende haben die sie
wählen können und dann wird man sich
anschauen wie das geht auch im moment
gibt es ja beispielsweise im
innenausschuss eine amtierende
vorsitzende das war die jenige die am
längsten dem parlament angehört dass
petra pau die selbstverständlich die
leitung diese die innenausschusssitzung
auch leiten kann also die ausschüsse
können arbeiten sie können gut arbeiten
und sie können nach allen
parlamentarischen gepflogenheiten
arbeiten und wir werden auch viel zu tun
haben in den ausschüssen deswegen aber
in diesem ausschuss läuft dafür die für
die afg nichts mehr in diesen drei
ausschüssen wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe das weiß ich nicht ich wer wir
werden ja sehen was die nächsten
vorschläge sind die jeder gemacht werden
und dann werden die parlamentarierinnen
und parlamentarier jeweils individuell
entscheiden und das ist auch bei einer
geheimen wahl gut weil dann nämlich
irgendwie klar ist dann entscheidet jede
und jeder für sich und es gibt nicht
irgendwie eine ansage das wird passieren
aber sie haben gefragt was ist wenn kein
vorsitzender der afg gewählt wird dann
wird es einen zweiten vize vorsitzender
in vietzen vorsitzenden geben und
deswegen ist die arbeitsfähigkeit eines
ausschuss auch jetzt schon in dieser
zwischenfall selbstverständlich
gewährleistet und darauf konzern das
klingt nun doch nach neuen
gepflogenheiten und neu aufgezogenen
seiten danke für das gespräch frau
göring-eckardt ich bedanke mich auch
wir hatten das gespräch vor einer guten
stunde im heute-journal update spricht
nase an guckte mir heute nacht mit der
linkspartei chefin janine wissler zum
gleichen thema in sachsen wurde heute
bei razzien erschüttern deutlich zu
welchen extremen sich misstrauen und
hass in den spalten der gesellschaft
hineinsteigern in den halb
abgeschotteten foren digitaler räume
eine reportage unserer kollegen arndt
ginzel und henrik merker von frontal hat
das letzte woche aufgedeckt und heute
zogen
strafverfolgungsbehörden mal
konsequenzen noch keine lösung lange
nicht für ein wachsendes problem
aber vielleicht ein anfang
es ist wohl das ende einer hilflosen
umsturz fantasie zumindest für fünf
männer und eine frau aus sachsen
allesamt mitglieder einer internet chat
gruppe heute früh bekamen sie besuch vom
lka wir haben eine woche nach der
ausstrahlung dieser sendung die ersten
tatverdächtigen ermittelt diese jet
gruppe ist wesentlich größer das können
also in der folge noch weitere maßnahmen
folgen insgesamt hatte die genannte
telegramm jet gruppe über 100 mitglieder
darunter auch die reporter die zuhörten
was sie erfuhren wirkte anfangs
befremdlich später alarmierend
[Musik]
mit dem typen bei dem man
reinmarschieren ihn rausziehen und
irgendwo aufhängen wollte war sachsens
ministerpräsident gemeint der
rechtsstaat habe sich wehrhaft gezeigt
sagt michael kretschmer heute und meint
dabei nicht nur sich selbst bedrohungen
gegen amtspersonen seines bürgermeister
gemeinderäte landräte aber auch
gegenüber wissenschaftlern und
journalisten sind nicht hinnehmbar
die chat gruppe versammelte offenbar
menschen mit ausgeprägter impfskepsis
manche von ihnen bereit diese skepsis
bis zum äußersten zu verteidigen
gewaltphantasien radikaler spinner oder
reale gefahr heute morgen fand das lka
tatsächlich armbrüste die frontal
autoren hatten die gruppe wochen lang
beobachtet die haben zeitweise märtyrer
gesucht nur anhänger gesucht die bereit
sind
bewaffnet quasi hier etwas zu
unternehmen
und
mein eindruck war die leben in einer
parallelwelt
völlig entkoppelt dessen was eigentlich
um sie herum noch passiert eine
parallelwelt aber eine mit dem anspruch
sich auszudehnen messenger dienste wie
telegramm bieten dafür den oft
rechtsextremen ideologen die reichweite
nahezu jede botschaft anonym zu
verbreiten botschaften an uns alle sagt
der beobachter es ist ein teil der
strategie der rechtsextremen
uns zu verunsichern uns das signal zu
geben als stünde morgen eine art
aufstand bevor das heißt wir müssen
gekonnt souverän aber trotzdem nicht
verunsichert reagieren im umgang mit
dieser mit dieser bedrohung ein appell
an die zivilgesellschaft die razzia in
dresden zeigt was sich im schutz des
internet zusammenbrauen kann aus der
politik kommen inzwischen erste signale
sich messenger-dienste genauer anzusehen
und gesetze anzupassen
wer in dieser nachrichtenlage positives
sucht könnte es beim thema impfstoff
finden minister lauterbach machte
gestern den eindruck dass bald mangel
daran herrschen würde das klingt heute
aber weniger beunruhigt die
bundesregierung will für 2 2 milliarden
euro zusätzliche corona impfstoffe
kaufen zuvor hatte sich
gesundheitsminister lauterbach besorgt
geäußert anfang des jahres könne zu
wenig impfstoff vorhanden sein sein
ministerium habe vorhandene mengen und
bedarf geprüft wegen der booster
impfungen und der gefahr durch die
omikron variante gehe es jetzt
kurzfristig um weitere käufe erklärte
lauterbach gemeinsam mit finanzminister
lindner der haushaltsausschuss hat die
notwendigen mittel freigegeben
wegen der weiterhin angespannten corona
lage ist in mainz der rosenmontagszug
abgesagt worden das zweite jahr in folge
der mainzer carneval verein als
veranstalter verzichtet auf den
höhepunkt der fasnacht zum kölner
rosenmontagszug gibt es noch keine
scheidung
in der aufarbeitung der rechtsextremen
nsu mord serie hat der bundesgerichtshof
ein großes kapitel beendet der
mammutprozess gegen die terrorzelle ist
abgeschlossen durch die bestätigung der
strafe von zweieinhalb jahren haft gegen
nsu unterstütze andreé der bgh lehnte
die revisionen von verteidigung und
anklage ab alle anderen urteile darunter
auch die lebenslange haft für beate
treppe sind schon rechtskräftig
die aus dem amt geschiedene
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer ist mit einem großen
zapfenstreich feierlich verabschiedet
worden dabei wünschte sich die cdu
politikerin unter anderem die
titelmelodie des westerns die
glorreichen sieben
kramp karrenbauer war knapp zwei jahre
lang verteidigungsministerin in ihrer
amtszeit fiel auch die schwierige
evakuierungs mission der bundeswehr aus
afghanistan
an der zeremonie im berliner
bendlerblock nahm auch die
amtsnachfolgerin lambrecht von der spd
teilen
im kleinen tiergarten mitten in berlin
am hellichten tag hat die russische
regierung vor zwei jahren einen menschen
ermorden lassen das ist seit heute keine
vermutung und auch keine bloße
pressemeldung mehr das ist nach
aufwändiger weiß aufnahme und prozess
ein urteil des berliner kammergerichts
ein ungewöhnlich scharf und deutlich
formuliert das urteil für den
angeklagten bedeutet es lebenslange haft
für deutsche außenpolitik und ministerin
berbalk eine heikle herausforderung
andreas künast berichtet
der insasse in blaulicht wagen nummer
eins ist beides hochgefährlich und hoch
gefährdet seine bewacher haben an
prozesstagen immer wieder rote und
fahrzeuge gewechselt die scheiben
jedesmal abgedunkelt bis heute hat keine
fernsehkamera war dem grassi kopf
gefilmt der russischer staatsbürger
offizier des geheimdienstes fsb und
auftragsmörder sein soll dass er gefasst
wird war nie vorgesehen
am vormittag verurteilt der
staatsschutzsenat des berliner
kammergerichts grassi kopf zu
lebenslanger haft und bezeichnet dessen
attentat unmissverständlich als
staatsterrorismus damit geht es um mehr
als einen kriminalfall damit geht es um
völkerrecht um politik am nachmittag
reagiert die bundesregierung
dieser mord in staatlichem auftrag wie
vom gericht heute festgestellt stellt
eine schwerwiegende verletzung deutschen
rechts und der souveränität der
bundesrepublik deutschlands da der
berliner alltag hat alles verschluckt
was noch erinnern könnte an den
helllichten augusttag vor zwei jahren
als im sogenannten kleinen tiergarten
der mutmassliche auftrag
füllt ist abtransportiert wird die
leiche von kommandeur langosch willi der
in tschetschenien gegen russland
gekämpft hat es war schon der dritte
anschlag die ersten zwei hat der
milizenführer überlebt terrorist bandit
verbrecher wird präsident putin in
nennen einen brutalen blutrünstigen
menschen das tat opfer ist in das visier
geraten durch seine freundschaft zum
russischen staat insbesondere durch
seine teilnahme an den kämpfen im
zweiten tschetschenienkrieg vor gericht
bestreitet classic rock klassikers zu
sein und alles andere auch der
angeklagte hat die tat bestritt der
angeklagte hat insbesondere bestritten
teil des russischen sicherheitsapparates
zu sein oder in auftrag und eines
sicherheitsapparates gehandelt zu haben
und dafür gibt es auch aus unserer sicht
kein einziges tragfähiges beweismittel
das gericht hält für erwiesen dass
staatliche stellen grassi kopf eine
falsche identität verschafften an der
russland bis heute festhält das
auswärtige amt bestellt moskaus
botschafter ein aus ohnehin schwer
belasteten beziehungen wird tiefste
krise der botschafter wurde mitgeteilt
dass zwei angehörige des diplomatischen
personals der russischen botschaft zu
unerwünschten personen erklärt werden
botschafter netschajew wehrt sich und
stellt die unabhängigkeit des gerichts
in frage wir halten dieses urteil für
eine voreingenommene und politisch
motivierte entscheidungen einen gibt es
der alles erzählen könnte bei dem grassi
kopf wird viele jahre vielleicht für
immer eingesperrt seien hochgefährlich
und hoch gefährdet
die auseinandersetzung mit putin
russlands verständnis von recht und
gerechtigkeit hatte heute einen zweiten
schauplatz in straßburg das
europaparlament verlieh dem
kreml-kritiker alexej nawalny den
sacharow menschenrechtspreis
die 20-jährige daria nadal musste in
straßburg für ihren vater sprechen der
haft und tod nicht scheut und doch
mittlerweile wehrlos scheint gegen die
kreml astiz sie verdient gehört
unbedingt
ich reise zu gipfeln und konferenzen
halte reden im namen meines vaters
aber er sitzt im gefängnis
und ich werde weiter reisen und artikel
lesen über die schrecklichen bedingungen
unter die an mein vater gefangen
gehalten wird und ich kann nichts
dagegen tun also reise ich unterhalte
reden und er ist in gefahr
ich verstehe nicht warum diejenigen die
für pragmatische beziehungen werden
nicht einfach mal ein geschichtsbuch
öffnen
diktatoren und tyrannen zu befrieden das
funktioniert nicht
unter dem deckmantel von pragmatismus
steckt zynismus scheinheiligkeit und
korruption in der europäischen politik
gibt es einen ständigen krieg zwischen
idealismus und pragmatismus aber wenn
man sich schon für den pragmatismus
entscheidet sollte man nicht seine
ideale verraten
das war ein bitterer sätze von dana war
naja an europa bitter aber wahr der
preis den europa ihrem vater verleiht
kann nur ein weiteres symbol sein von
der sorte von der ist schon einen großen
haufen gibt die wirtschaftsredaktion
hierzulande wussten heute dass sie
eigentlich wichtige meldungen für die
finanzwelt heute erst kommt wenn es in
europa schon abend ist die finanzmärkte
warteten heute mit großer spannung auf
entscheidungen der us notenbank
es wurde damit gerechnet dass fed chef
paul einen schnelleren ausstieg aus den
wertpapierkäufen ankündigen und
vielleicht etwas zu einer ersten
zinsanhebung sagen würde valerie was ist
aktuell aus washington zu hören und wie
kommt das an den börsen an also
tatsächlich will die amerikanische
notenbank nun deutlich schneller als
geplant aus ihrem corona hilfsprogramm
aussteigen kommen da märz könnte dann
schluss damit sein ja und außerdem fasst
die fed fürs kommende jahr drei
zinserhöhungen ins auge deutlich mehr
als erwartet
anlegern gefällt dass die notenbanker
gegen die inflation vorgehen der dow
jones ordentlich im plus keine
selbstverständlichkeit wenn eine
notenbank den geldhahn zudreht die fed
zeigt zähne zu groß der druck durch die
davon galoppierende inflation in den usa
lag sie zuletzt bei 6,8 lange hat auch
fed chef paul an der these festgehalten
die inflation sei pandemie bedingt und
nur vorübergehend inzwischen aber geht
auch er davon aus dass sich die
inflation erst ende kommenden jahres
normalisiert dies ist die woche der
notenbanken morgen wird sich die
europäische zentralbank zu ihrer
geldpolitik äußern sie ist jedoch viel
zurückhaltender hält den inflationsschub
weiter für er kurzfristig eine
zinserhöhung im kommenden jahr sehr
unwahrscheinlich der dax zurückhaltend
im vorfeld der notenbanksitzungen ins
plus hatte sich dann aber am schluss
doch noch gerettet die europäische
zentralbank kommt immer mehr unter
zugzwang die rufe werden lauter die
inflation ernster als bislang zu nehmen
und die zügel zu straffen
bahnbrechendes wird für morgen aber
erstmal nicht erwartet und trotzdem
werden wir berichten vielen dank valerie
nach frankfurt
englische woche in der fußball
bundesliga hier sind die restlichen
ergebnisse des sechzehnten spieltages
gladbach unterlag eintracht frankfurt 2
3 borussia dortmund besiegte greuther
fürth 13 0 bayer leverkusen und
hoffenheim trennten sich 2 2 union
berlin und freiburg torlos und augsburg
und rb leipzig eins zu eins
fehlen noch die gewinnzahlen vom lotto
am mittwoch sie lauten 4
15 17 26
28 superzahl 2 weitere gewinnzahlen auf
lotto zdf de und im zdf text
die stadt nürnberg aus der das
naziregime so eine art mekka ihrer
ideologie gemacht hatten muss bis heute
mit den hinterlassenschaften des dritten
reiches fertig werden die kongresshalle
einzig und allein dafür da den führer
einmal im jahr eine bühne mit 50.000
gefolgsleuten zu füßen zu legen blieb
als bauruine stehen weil hitlers
wahnsinns krieg dem wahnsinns- bau in
die quere kam über 70 jahre hat die
stadt mit diesen bedrückenden erbe
gerungen es mal banalisiert mal
kultiviert mal ignoriert und jetzt soll
es schlicht genutzt werden für kultur
einplanen der umstritten sein muss beide
seiten haben argumente berichten stefan
leifert und peter meyer
man tut sich schwer es einen ort zu
nennen was die nazis mit dem
reichsparteitagsgelände
hinterließen ist stein gewordener
größenwahn ein unort denn nürnberg mal
wieder vor die frage gestellt was tun
damit darf die leichtigkeit der musik in
die monstrosität der hitler bauten
einziehen es gab einen ort solcher
größenordnung vorher nicht wenn man die
bedeutung dieser einzigartigkeit wir
sprechen hier von einer gewaltherrschaft
sondersgleichen im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert verstehen will dann muss man
so einen ort möglichst authentisch
lassen um den menschen die gelegenheit
zu geben aus diesem umgang mit der
geschichte zu lernen
es ist dieser ort der die diskussion
überhaupt erst entstehen ließ in
nürnbergs opernhaus proben sie gerade
das narrenschiff das gebäude historisch
unverdächtig aber marode
die sanierung wird jahre dauern
nürnbergs hochkultur braucht ein
ausweichquartier
doch darf im nazi ballett getanzt werden
man darf man muss sagt joachim hamburger
um den nazis das gebäude zu entreißen
wir machen uns klein gegenüber den nazis
die dieses gebäude hier hingestellt
haben wir dürfen es nicht dulden dass
die plötzlich die deutungshoheit über
diese gebäude behalten wir müssen
versuchen das zu konterkarieren
wo die nazis einst führerkult und
größenfantasien inszenierten soll also
bald die kunst einziehen den ort der
unkultur
zurückverwandeln in einen ort der freien
offenen gesellschaft nicht kleiner ist
der anspruch den nürnberg an sich stellt
zehn jahre wird das
reichsparteitagsgelände zum
ausweichquartier für nürnbergs
staatstheater so hat es der stadtrat
heute mit breiter mehrheit beschlossen
wir müssen auch an diesem ort wo dieser
ort zum denken anregen muss das kann
kultur und deshalb ist es die richtige
entscheidung auch ein interview von
einem opernhaus hier mit einziehen zu
lassen es ist kein mahnmal es ist kein
gedenkort wie eben ein vernichtung sword
sondern darüber hinaus eben auch ein ort
der vielleicht gerade um genutzt werden
sollte um immer wieder demokratischen
gespräch zu bleiben
nürnbergs opernchor ist erleichtert nun
endlich ein quartier während des umbaus
zu haben
und dass hitlers unort könnte 82 jahren
nach bauer bruch doch noch ein ort
werden
bei uns weitet sich gleich der horizont
mit dem auslandsjournal zdf
korrespondent in den berichten unter
anderem über chinas
null-toleranz-politik gegen korona die
zahlen dort scheinen beneidenswert
niedrig die frage ist um welchen preis
das sehen wir gleich und um 0.50 ist
derzeit für unser heute schon mal update
mit nah sein dürften bis morgen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter noch bleibt es
relativ mild aber ab der kommenden woche
wird es allmählich kühler werden und vor
allem dann bis zum ende des monats
relativ kalt das ist hier ein beispiel
für hamburg berlin und münchen und dass
es noch mild bleibt liegt an dem hoch
was sich ja kaum verändertes war bat
höchstens nach norden hin und etwas nach
osten und dadurch gibt es durchaus
einige sonnen anteile mehr vor allem
dann nach norden hin und da lockert es
in der nacht schon auf und auch im süden
in der mitte sind zahlreiche wolken
dabei und es tröpfelt wieder etwas aus
der dichten wolkendecke
es ist wieder sprühregen tiefsten
temperaturen von minus vier grad an den
alpen und 8 grad in schleswig-holstein
morgen im tagesverlauf reißt es an der
ostsee regelrechte auf die gibt es viel
sonnenschein und auch nach osten hin
genauso im suhler zeigt sich auch häufig
die sonne dazwischen wieder viele wolken
gelegentlich wieder einige tropfen
sprühregen bei höchsten temperaturen von
zwei grad an den alpen und vor allem
nach norden in bei neuen teils bis zu 10
grad im westen und nördlich der
mittelgebirge ja und die nächsten tage
am freitag im osten etwas regen sonst
lockert es auf die sonne zeigt sich zwei
bis zehn grad und des wochenendes wird
größtenteils trocken sein und hier und
da zeigt sich häufiger die sonne damit
ein schöner abend